(intense music)
(upbeat music)
- [Kurt Braunohler]
Soggy log, June 1st.
I've ridden 250 miles
in the last two days,
and we've only raised $10,000.
It's only enough to send 100
goats to families in Africa.
How do I get people
excited about this mission?
Maybe I just haven't done
enough for people right here,
in the good ol' U.S. of A.
Time to change that.
(energetic music)
(singing) ♪ Personal watercraft.
♪ Personal watercraft.
So we met Kaylee
the night before,
and Kaylee tells us
that she's graduating
from high school
the very next day.
And we're just
like, "Oh, Kaylee."
"Do you wanna ride a
jet ski to graduation?"
(audience laughing)
And Kaylee's like,
"Fuck yes, I do!"
Like a caterpillar
coming out of a cocoon,
high school graduation is
maybe the most important time
of a young lady's life.
Until she experiences
anything after that.
Hey Kaylee!
- Hey!
You're my ride, aren't ya?
- I'm your ride.
- All right.
- All right, get on here.
You're gonna graduate!
Welcome to being an adult!
It's all as good as this!
(cheering)
Kaylee's ready to
get wasted tonight!
- Hell yeah!
- Hell yes.
- [Both] No more school!
No more school!
- You can do anything you want!
Who ya gonna vote for now?
- I don't even know politics.
- Who gives a shit?
- Not me!
- Kaylee, what're ya
gonna be when you grow up?
- A nurse practitioner.
- Now that you're 18, you
can totally milk a cow.
- I can milk a cow.
- You legally can milk a cow.
That's one of the laws
of the United States.
- Are you being dead serious?
- Nope.
- Oh. (laughs)
- Nope, no, I think you can
milk a cow whenever you want.
- Okay.
- And then I drop her
off at graduation,
you know, like, ready
for her to just transform
into the nurse practitioner
she was always meant to be.
And it was like my jet ski had
become this weird,
wet cocoon, y'know,
and Kaylee had got
on a caterpillar,
and got off a butterfly destined
to get wasted in the woods.
(audience laughing)
It was beautiful.
And then the whole thing was
we're gonna go to Kaskaskia.
Kaskaskia is the smallest
town in Illinois.
And it's fascinating.
This place used to have
thousands of people,
and then the Mississippi
changed direction around it
and killed everyone in the town.
And now there's 14 people left.
And then I'm gonna
give them this present,
like I have a big
surprise for everybody.
Here we are in Kaskaskia.
I'm gonna try and meet every
single person in Kaskaskia.
And give 'em bundt cake.
And invite them to a gift
that I'm giving to the town.
(knocking)
- I've got a bundt cake for
everybody, just as a gift.
everybody who
lives in Kaskaskia.
- Well, thank you!
- You're welcome!
I've got cameras just following
me because I'm jet skiing
from Chicago to New Orleans,
and I happened to
stop in Kaskaskia,
and I found out that it is
the second smallest
town in Illinois.
- There's only three,
five, maybe eight
of us that lives here.
- I thought it was 14.
So you guys are the
smallest town in Illinois.
- I mean, someone's moved out.
- Oh yeah, someone moved out
and you actually got it
back to the smallest town.
Have a good day!
- Yeah, you too.
- Only eight.
So what's interesting
is, talked to that lady,
eight people.
There's only eight
people, which is perfect,
'cause we only have
nine bundt cakes.
So I think we can
literally meet everyone.
There's a house, let's
see if anybody's home.
(knocking)
- [Man] Hello there, hi.
- Hi, how are you?
- Real good, you?
- Good.
I'm just going around trying
to meet everybody in Kaskaskia,
and I wanted to give
you this bundt cake.
- Okay, well I'll say thank ya.
- Oh you're welcome.
- Appreciate it.
- I brought you a bundt cake.
- [Woman] Oh, well,
they're delicious, yes.
- Here ya go.
- He belongs to a
neighbor down the street.
(laughing)
- This town used to
have 7,000 people in it.
And then the Mississippi river
changed direction around it,
wiping it out, and
it's only because of
one piece of concrete
that it doesn't
successfully destroy
it every year.
But then every 20
years, it does!
Never been to a house that
starts on the second story.
Hello!
- [Woman] Hello!
- [Kurt] Bundt cake delivery.
Thanks, guys.
- Thanks, take care.
- [Kurt] So everybody's been
pretty overwhelmingly friendly.
I was more expecting if you
live in a town with 14 people,
that you kind of,
maybe, hate people?
But maybe it's the opposite.
It's a choice,
because you want to
live somewhere that you love.
And I respect that,
I like that a lot.
It feels weird
saying to everybody,
without telling them what
it is: I got you a gift.
It sounds like I'm a lunatic.
But...
I don't want to tell
them what it is.
I want them to be surprised.
All right, on count of three
you're gonna turn around,
and we will reveal
the gift to Kaskaskia.
One.
Two.
Three.
Turn around.
(laughing)
(townspeople cheering)
- [Woman] They got
kitties, Mary Ellen.
- [Woman in Hat] How did
you happen to get cats?
(laughing)
She's our cat person.
- [Kurt] Well, that'll be up
there, at least for a month.
- [Woman in Hat] That's
great, well thank you so much.
- Thank you guys so much.
Thank you guys so much,
let's come in for a huge.
- To Kaskaskia!
- The biggest little
town in Illinois.
- [Man] Ready, on three.
- Put it in, one, two, three.
- [All] One.
Two.
Three.
Kaskaskia!
- These people live in a
town that completely floods
every 20 years.
I mean, I expected to either
find grade A fuckin' lunatics,
or morons, like a
bunch of dumb birds
who keep makin' their
nests in a canon, y'know?
But instead I found
the kindest people.
People who loved
where they lived,
even if it might kill them.
(audience laughs)
And I get that, that's
cool, I'm from Jersey.
We're the same way.
(audience laughing)
Fuckin' right on, Kaskaskia.
Long live the Boss.
Kaskaskia taught me a lot.
If you just reach out to people,
don't be scared to talk to them.
Even if they only live in
a town with eight people.
They're still
gonna be very happy
to have a conversation with you,
especially if you got a cake.
(energetic music)
Hey!
Africa needs bundt cakes
too, America, so donate!
Click right here and
donate to Africa!
Come on, what're
you waiting for?